[Musique]
un rugbyman du stade toulousain au pays
des footballeurs sofiane guitoune
travail avec maxence pionniers
préparateur physique du centre médical
de clairefontaine accélération sur 20
mètres changements d'appuis et de
vitesse des exercices pour solliciter
les adducteurs du sportif
l'objectif était vraiment de le
recentrer sur ses sensations et pour
voir si lui santé un déséquilibre au
niveau du cycle des gens mois antérieur
sofiane guitoune 28 ans trois quarts
polyvalent du stade toulousain 5
sélections dans le quinze de france une
participation aux jeux olympiques de rio
en 2016 avec l'équipe de france à vii
depuis plusieurs semaines il effectue sa
rééducation au centre médical de
clairefontaine après avoir contracté une
pubalgie il ya deux ans il se fait
opérer une première fois en début
d'année à la paroi abdominale
malgré l'intervention la douleur est
toujours présente du coup quand je me
suis fait opérer à fin avril le
chirurgien m'a parlé de clairefontaine
et c'était possible de venir faire sa
rééducation ici et que voilà quoi
c'était le domaine des footeux et que
j'ai l'habitude de soigner ce genre de
blessure pubalgie c'est vraiment une
blessure difficile à gérer il ya des
hauts et des bas et il faut faire avec
c'est jamais tout rose et voilà la
semaine dernière ça avait très très bien
en début de semaine c'était un peu
compliqué là ça va mieux après le
terrain place au renforcement musculaire
une rééducation d'une trentaine d'heures
par semaine suivie de près par le staff
du stade toulousain
une harmonisation des charges de travail
entre le centre médical de
clairefontaine et le club des soins pour
une meilleure récupération à la fois
s'occuper de ses parois et ses
adducteurs
donc le but c'est vraiment de
réharmoniser la zone le centre médical
existe depuis onze ans on retrouve des
consultations pour tous les sportifs
qu'ils soient amateurs ou professionnels
la section rééducation destiné aux
sportifs de haut niveau
priorité aux footballeurs mais pas
seulement rugbyman basketteurs
handballeurs ou même danseur de
breakdance
donc on essaye
voilà d'avoir de la diversité et ce qui
est intéressant pour tout le monde aussi
bien pour nous pour varier un petit peu
le type de pathologie le type d'exercice
à mettre en place
le séjour de sofiane guitoune à
clairefontaine se termine ce jeudi 13
juillet reprise de l'entraînement avec
le stade toulousain à la fin du mois un
convoi exceptionnel prix dans un épais
brouillard arrive de dreux lente
procession brillant de tous ses feux
la caravane est porteuse une bonne
nouvelle pour l'église de saint quentin
des sources à montigny depuis sa
construction achevée en juin 1992
l'église n'avait pas de clocher tout
juste un beffroi vide avec une croix en
bois provisoire aujourd'hui la cie
inoxydable a remplacé le bois et
l'église a hérité de son clocher
surmonté d'un paratonnerre lacroix
trônera désormais au dessus de ses
structures aux 2 16 m pour quatre mètres
de large ce campanile version moderne
est plus de deux tonnes et roy nécessité
deux mois de travail avant de loger deux
clochers dans son emplacement définitif
on lastic religieusement une création
que les architectes ont voulu très
dépouillée on a opté pour un dessin
minimale
j'ai juste une structure un peu comme
les clochers catalan destinés à
supporter les supporter les cloches le
moment crucial est arrivé lentement
lacroix s'élève dans le ciel et au prix
d'une manoeuvre délicate valait de cette
grue de 40 mètres rejoindre la place qui
lui est réservé dans le beffroi images
mémorables pour la paroisse
des instants spectaculaire que le père
de l'église saint quentin et source n'a
pas hésité caméscope au poing
du haut de sa nacelle enregistré pour la
postérité
avant l'arrivée des cloches
alors les clash c'est pour la semaine
prochaine livre est probablement si ce
n'est l'autre est posée en tout cas
bénigne le 6 mars
avant cette bénédiction le mois prochain
le clocher devra subir encore quelques
aménagements supplémentaires
[Musique]